this is mr. Mack he's an elder bro  tortoise a giant tortoise species that  can live past 180 and may have the  longest lifespan of any creature on the  planet hailing from the Eldora Atoll a  small cluster of coral islands in the  Indian Ocean build-a-bra tortoise is  massive endowed with a domed shell long  neck and strong claws they can grow to  be longer than four feet and can weigh  as much as 500 pounds they live in  grasslands and subsist on a diet of dry  nutrient-rich vegetation and Aldabra  tortoises never met a blade of grass it  didn't like and it won't be deterred  from eating it even if it takes a while  to reach it but the tortoises have had a  harder time finding food because of  habitat destruction caused by humans and  increasingly climate change this is the  Aldabra tortoise  [Music]  you  [Music]